no no no no no no no al essa abbia
raggiunto i 700 metri shelly grazie come
cambiamento 700mila abbiamo cambiato il
vostro sfondo e voleva la konami ha
imparato soprattutto per una festa di
compleanno ha detto e adesso dobbiamo
portare tutto il rinfresco e mangiavo
tutto l'inter
così gli altri nei commenti che cosa
fare come speciale 700 mila iscritti
avete tutte le vostre idee quelle che ci
piace di più proveremo a far le facciamo
mangiare d'italia dal live gratta e
vinci inventata da noi ma anche grazie
ai vostri consigli perché se non avete
visto il video in cui affronto delle
sorprese di tiger tutte le buste sue
priorità e caravate vedremo dopo questo
video come abbiamo trovato delle specie
di adesivi grate di sicuro lo abbiamo
già trattato da provare per vedere come
era vero era bianco dentro quindi
abbiamo capito che noi non omettere le
cose pietro e abbiamo subito pensato non
facciamo un'assise sarà così anche
invece lo avete scritto nei commenti
quindi abbiamo preparato le varie
caselline con i numeri in ogni caselli
nazioni ingrediente che può essere un
ingrediente buono o un ingrediente
sfigato o brutto quindi a prescindere
prese grattiamo vinceremo buco un
ingrediente per fare nel drive oppure
esistono delle case linee speciali in
cui puoi scegliere tu cosa prendere un
oppure nelle caselline sfidate in cui
l'altra persona sceglie cosa rendere
divertente
tante le ultime delle altre gialle zaia
consigliati sicure quali altre challenge
line per riportare di siamo solidali
primo round non vi abbiamo detto che
sono numerate le cartelline e fra l'ex
sceglierà il numero ci ho già firmato
sveglia allora vediamo innanzitutto chi
siamo
campovolo preso sasso che dai numeri di
cardella
ok sono 11 al essa di un numero a caso
tra 111 due impronte a grattare la
casellina numero 26 pronto a trattare
solo sulla carta tratta di reatò curiosa
e gli skipper buonissimo bordo che
fortunata ha propagato la nostra solo
stimola barba che fortuna della tracolla
per fortunato morale della dritta con
gli studenti
[Applauso]
una bella cosa ma dipendente un'altra di
capitan situazioni proprio scivolato ma
che limita le è stato fortunato e ha già
la schermata al essa sei un numero a
caso tra 111 11 non so perché ma ho un
po paura di quella lunga non lo stato
non mi convince molto
vediamo quindi vediamo questo che cosa
no cosa no no no no no no no vedo
qualcosa diverte a sky
no dai no no ma cosa ma perché per me
graffa tutto mi aspetto cioè ma questo è
il verde il giallo è giallo giallo rosso
arancione ma che era un arcobaleno stile
arancione giallo blù e poi questi soloni
clijster col quale è appunto la riusciva
unica
in di glitter arcobaleno e sei contento
per lì ok allora i colori che ci sono
sono rosso quindi vado a vedere prof che
buffon ha poi giallo giallo bardelli
turco valero e poi c'è il verde
purtroppo dura ma va dai tanto verrà
minimo impatto oramai verde infatti
allison tutto l'inverno detto non mi
dire è che sono già fatto così sfigata
invece noto l'arcobaleno
poi c'è il blu blu e poi c'è il viola e
lo metto qua perché non ha coperto molto
che bello bellissimo ho paura che non
rimarrà così una volta che l'ho visto
però ma mischiato qui vai
vediamo un po come diventa via sono
bellissimi questi colori mischiati
insieme allora un po sono spariti perché
la con le bianca però non del tutto
comunque si vedono un bel po e sono
abbastanza luccicanti quindi sono
comunque contenta di avere tanti clipper
aver colorato per più di lei è bella è
tutto bianco il viola in bianco
qualche colore protesisti rassicuranti
si no loro abbiamo sa che è stato
fissato a ogni partito bene ed ha fatto
dai l'ex a dimmi un numero tra 3 e 11 9
numero anni speriamo speriamo che sia un
numero sfortunato e no anche vediamo un
po cosa si nella casella numero 9 dai
capi lo sfigato che quello sfigato che
dello sfigato e un bianco c'è una cosa
giallo ma che fortunato si crescerà
uscirà lo slime team hoppla fuoco ma
anche ma batte per ma non possiamo
capitarti quello bere da quello marrone
quello nero e cappello larga sia né dopo
la fine la pena vorrei un di hr ad
ingrediente che terrò qui a milano è
fortunata dopo che l'attivo lo
aggiungerò ma perché tocca un esterno
che all ex sia brava oppure se cantina
al essa se il numero a caso tra 3 e 11
766 perché è una dei menu e preferisce
quindi speriamo che ci sia qualcosa di
fortuna vi porterà war 2
[Musica]
no no su piani anch'io voglio
raggiungerlo dopo quindi qualsiasi altro
cliente vi capiterà adesso anche se
bello so che poi questo filo rubini ai
reds perché in verde e il velino marca
giovani stata buffa carta fuori
disastrata
non so se sono io che ho detto sempre
formi sono io che cosa processo contro
però a me mi è andata male ea me bene
dai
alexa sceglie un numero tra 311 speriamo
che non canti sceglie un numero tra 3 e
11 55
cosa ti senti mi sento che uscirà un
ingrediente bellissimo vediamo vediamo
cosa conterrà questo 5
e allora qui è tutto il bianco non vedo
qualcosa perché marrone comitato tutela
d'onda c'era è una capolona
e sai cosa vuol dire questa cosa così
creduto nel bagno a vomitare verso il
secco
fammi pensare cose che troppo imbruttire
colorante casino perché magari controllo
di contestare bene però inutile marroni
dai metti la metti la perfida mette un
po di fortuna per me stai attento però è
perché se lo faccio nero adesso mi esce
poi mi escono tutti i brillantini lo
cosa fosse proprio grazie grazie
biancardi tutto grigio adesso e poi con
il giallo anch'io sport uniti messo così
non è stato molto veloce nero si no così
esce per uno che ne resta perché bianco
e tanto qui ecco perché ci voleva tanto
nero sembra un buco nero
utilissimo però ha il suo fascino e gli
stati d'animo questo nero nero nero
milano mi ha nominato lo slide si
perfida liberalizzando mamma ha detto
cammello e diamo se all'esame porterà
facciamo al ex a segno il numero tra 3
11 59 ma restano ti ricordi niente alexa
se di un numero tra 3 11 5 palesa 70
purtroppo non tra voglia di spostare non
aiuta
alexa sceglierà tra 3 e 11 55 abbiamo
capito galex ogni caso il 5 e il 9 set
ci sono quelli che già so ha detto alex
se il numero a caso tra 3 11 carote 5
purtroppo nella saletta scegli un numero
alexa scegli un numero a caso tra 3 e 11
scegli un numero a caso tra 3 11 11
[Applauso]
vediamo un po cosa c'è nel nostro mi
dissi che sarebbe dunque la tv giallo
rosa e giallo forse qualcosa di positivo
non è che tutta la fortuna con la
cacchetta d'oro posso scegliere io
qualsiasi ingrediente un avanzo realtà
non so bene cosa scegliere a chi scelgo
un bellissimo colorante che colorata
sceglierai qualcosa che possa cancellare
il verde il giallo
mi viene da dire viola però poi magari
diventa marrone
[Musica]
tutti ci rivediamo pesca lo faccio
perche non so come uscirà col verde poi
va beh forse uscirà carino per me
mercante tanta gente mentre la rosa
allora con tutto quel bianco si volta
però con il verde una cosa come
dimetterà spesso non diventi marrone
forse dovevamo vedere o meglio se
prendevo il celeste così almeno 90
cerette aqua diode per il momento è
terreno così vedremo dopo come diventa
sembrano fragola toccano ok musik ed è
vanificato da fare che una maestra
stessi comportamenti mentana nextar alex
scegli un numero a caso tra 3 e 10 si
sono con me diceva 5 cattiva azione
perché alex mi ascolta io sono molto
molto carino con le piccole come brava
l'ex granata vediamo un po cosa se nelle
due fratellini stay speriamo qualcosa di
sfigato si è data molto slime c'è poco
da
sempre nella parola cosa cattiva
te lo consiglio io come aggiungere un po
di colorante viola ma non ti bene in
quel nero giallo filippo andare facciamo
che riguarda i glitter si vedono nemmeno
effettivamente quali basta scendere più
di 12 perché non si vendono per niente
ma può essere che si veda il mio volo
cielo c'è un dispetto
e poiché non sono belle vere e si perde
perché non c'è il rispetto la rido metto
il verbo bene si vede per certo che si
vedono bene diavoletti mediche per
controllo hai visto cosa provavo a
scendere yacht
vediamo un po noi chiediamo un po di sé
di bernard di vita l'ex in nero ma li
sta coprendo ho ucciso né quando si vede
ancora mai perché non c'erano più perché
non era proprio una bella fetta
minuscole ora rimangono pochi numeri
fissi sono forse le cose
alexa se il numero a caso tra 3 e 10 10
sì non lo so vediamo se sono fortunato
perché la casa al primo colpo
poi il nostro 10 proviamo a indovinare
prima faccio una striscia qualcosa
diverte io vedo qualcosa di verde il che
non mi convince per niente prova a
grattare di più no dai
ma nuovamente voglio dire devo beccare i
verdi no no aspetta arancione
poter riprendere tutto questo almeno 100
veniva spesso con l'ex deciso maledetta
l'ex sera proprio con me oddio cosa ha
detto alex da kid maledetta avevo
pianificato tutto
ecco qua la colla verde che anche un po
sporca perché non so se vi ricordate
colazione da caravaggio che bisogna
aiutare tra la college di e camminato
con lo stomaco un po come si sta mio
bellissimo rosa con la colla verde era
perfetto in questo rosa fragola
kimberlain distrutto da verde watch
[Musica]
ma ci starà benissimo farà di questo
slime un colore marrone magari
diventando un po giallino fragalà
scaduta fra condotti ma per fortuna non
ha cambiato troppo il colore per una
fragolina una fragola un po acerba per
caselle due delle quali le prenderemo
noi e in ultimo nessuno quindi speriamo
che nell'ultima sia qualcosa dischi
fosse così non lo prendo io migliori
funzione proprio tesoro ultimo round di
farmi del 61 tra 3 e 8 3 bene io faccio
una striscia o un brutto presentimento
riesco a capire che cosa
[Musica]
tutti ma in rosa strade di coda
il bonus lettera si ripete che non è
uguale a lei questo la vendetta perché
nel conto la sua invero palezza cattiva
mi dispiace non ho mai cattive
intenzioni di sempre maggiore guardate
che carlino ed è capitato a te insieme
al bared a montieri qua visiva merda
raggiungere dopo la faccia così impara
da bill nero distanza vertenza che
uscirà un forum
lo vedono ora chissà voi sceglierà alex
alex ha per un numero tra 4 e 8 8 8
quindi quattro su quello che non
utilizzeremo vediamo vediamo un po cosa
c'è in questo è bianco ma poteva
capitare a me è tutto inutile fare
niente perché del tubo come dono ed era
un bel 10
ma non serve a niente ma con l'amore di
mentire dopo andiamo a vedere cosa ci
siamo persi solo 4 tieni che spreco di
nuovo mondo tra l'altro la via preferita
tu hai voluto tenere voluto rec è voluto
affidarmi lo slide col colore nero
guarda come ci sta bene invece uscirà un
bel galaxy un bel niente
uscirà un kalac sisma foto ma devo poi
aggiungere anche il giallo fine il play
giallo aspetta magari una boccetta
caso rea non mi chiamo unica unità
[Musica]
vediamo ora cosa ci siamo persi al
numero 4 al numero 4 questo non è di
nessuno
qualcosa di nuovo cosa di bello ma non
pensi mi
sam idoneo di habitat e sono proprio col
petto guarda creditizio tutti gli
ingredienti super divertente
ok allora ora andiamo ad attivare il
nostro slam
poi una volta tv lo facciamo vedere e
poi aggiungiamo la play assieme a voi
così vediamo come si trasforma siete
pronti 32 bellissimo adesso guardate che
bella un bellissimo colore tutti i
pallini dei glitter sembrano drive prego
lino sembrano tra molina anche la
consistenza del video così istante di
che colore diventerà del picchiato con
fornaca foro di clay ei verde vediamo
come diventa rosa chiaro e verde
mannaggia vi sia un po
[Musica]
spalmiamo la bene allora ora che non è
mischiato del tutto è molto bello perché
le sfumature delle strisce verdi quindi
così è bello però purtroppo non rimarrai
così una volta picchiato del tutto ma
ora andiamo ad aggiungere il morale kakà
le giacchette ecco qua la capienza
prendiamo un po come dimette con la
cache trovando giro terrebbe il fondo
può dire tu lo diventerà io penso che
diventi una sorta di rigetto marroncino
ci vediamo sta diventando un po grigio
vediamo chi vincerà la tv era tempo che
sfumature ragazzi 23 verdi marroni mamma
mia che punto grigia barre
quindi si è indurito un po dal play e
col bellissimo rosa è andato tutto mio
e diventato un grigio verte marroncino
ecco qua quindi questo il mio slide
vediamo ora quelle di vita le ho mai una
cacata nera parecchio interesse di
canzoni live che abbonato non ho
attivato troppo perché sennò vi dite che
è vitale attiva troppo e che dice ho
attivato di meno il colore è un
bellissimo nero quasi quasi quasi cucito
e un pochettino grigio in realtà che
suoni pochi invece siamo quasi molto
famoso per la schiuma da barba e
l'elastico super elastico e adesso
andiamo ad aggiungere il play giallo che
bello che lo dovrebbe migliorare
quindi che cosa succederà poi gliela
tira dritto
devi portare sfiga allora proviamo a
mischiarlo è d'oro che bello
a tutte con la carne che per lo slime
non pepita d'oro festa è stupendo oddio
sta diventando un pochettino grigie così
è perché adesso che si sta mischiando un
pochettino di più il giallo lo staff
dello centrale più sinceramente il
colore medesimi a conosco per porre
diventata così prima cosa abbiamo con
loro compitino
hai visto bello devo dirvi non me
l'aspettavo
il merito è uscito un bel batte
spalmabile che ho vinto tra tutte voi
nessuno perché sono brutti entrambi è in
sé giocando con quello di evitare perché
il nostro molto più sua foto il mio
diritto po come parlare dei miei sly un
gesto di bach iniziate vinco josé pinto
vitale per i nostri altri video di
calcolare preferita in quale ciao